Have you heard about those political promises?
Different political parties make different promises.
Before upcoming elections in Poland,
students are being promised,
for example,
that dorms will cost only one Polish latte,
which is an equivalent of 22 cents.
There will be various scholarships for dorms
on medical and military studies.
Every student will gain 1000 college loan,
which is an equivalent of 220 euro monthly
scholarship,
building and expanding infrastructure.
Some parties do not offer anything specifically
directly to students.
Do you think that political parties
should focus on students? Needs more